so the summary of this talk is callbacks
promises observables and what comes
after observables okay what goes beyond
rxjs let me tell you a little bit about
the history of a sink and the his
history of callbacks they didn't just do
some reset of my thing here okay let's
go back sorry so in the beginning
Brendan Eich he had 10 days to write
JavaScript I don't know if you knew
about that so of course he was in a
hurry
right so he was like very busy coding
and then on the tenth day someone said
stop and then he stopped so this picture
is a historical picture that portrays
Brendan Eich at the moment that he
stopped programming JavaScript ok and as
you see you know he was very tired but
he did actually a good job in ten days
he was able to make a lot of important
things one of the basic things was just
callbacks ok basic stuff you click on
the button and you want to like just
register a callback to run this alert
back in the days we used a lot of alerts
I don't know if you remember it was
horrible
so this was ok for a while for a while
callbacks were totally fine until
something came along called nodejs and
with nodejs we had suddenly like fetch
things from the database fetch things
from this file system and then we ended
up with code that looks like this this
is hell ok
I hope that yeah the font size should be
okay and yeah this is very bad because
it really twisted our brains and it made
us go really wild and it got all this
pyramid shape which is horrible so some
people came with solutions for this one
of them is called async jeaious raise
your hand if you have heard of use async
Geist it's a very old library by kaolin
and it helped this problem for a while
that if you wanted to you know check if
all of these files exists you could do
that like
so you could run things in parallel or
in series and that was nice
in the meantime jQuery was a thing and
they had this thing called deferred and
that was basically like a promise and
then they started standardizing promises
and we ended up with something that
looks like this so you can convert this
type of thing into this type of chain
one of Venables is what they had as a
name at the time and this was okay but
all of these things like async j/s and
promises we're mostly concerned with I
need to fetch this thing from the
database this one thing not multiple
things so we didn't have promises of
clicks for instance so around that time
Eric Meyer who's Dutch at the time was
working on my in Microsoft and he had
this idea what if your mouse would be a
database so you could fetch the latest
Mouse and you know query the mouse
clicks and that kind of stuff and he
created this thing for dotnet called
rx or reactive extensions and not in a
long time we got our X for JavaScript
called rxjs so I've been teaching rxjs
for four years and one of the most
famous blog posts I wrote and I've been
also like I wrote a framework on it and
I've been teaching it in workshops so I
know this thing from inside out but one
of the things that I was curious about
was I don't actually need rxjs for this
case ok this case basically listens to
an interval I can show how this what
this does I mean it just gives the
numbers over time you know of course I
could just do this without rx I could
just delete this part I can delete that
part and you know this is gonna do
exactly the same as I had before so
what's the point of rxjs I mean we just
limited and it eliminated a lot of
kilobytes and it was still same
functionality so of course our X J's
have these things called operators like
map and filter and scan and all of these
are very
useful there are like over a hundred of
them so it's all about the magic of
operators and how to use those things
you know so I thought okay but you could
also build operators for this thing
these things so for instance I could
write a filter not gonna go through the
details but you know I wrote filter here
and then I can apply filter on that same
subscribe function that I had with this
condition that I only want even numbers
so that's an operator and I wrote it
without rxjs and this is number ten and
you know I get even numbers over time so
I thought okay I can have operators and
I don't need rxjs so what what do I need
from rxjs then right one of the things
I'm missing did anyone notice it's like
I'm subscribing but I'm not
unsubscribing so it's actually kind of
challenging for me to make some kind of
unsubscribe here and that bugged me for
a while because I thought like is it
really so that unsubscribe is the only
thing that we need from rxjs and I
thought about this for a while and one
day I was in the airplane and it clicked
and I saw like yeah and I was so excited
that I took my phone out and I attached
my keyboard to it and I started
prototyping some stuff and it came out
to be pretty exciting and this is what
I'm gonna share with you today this kind
of stuff okay so I did this in the plane
you can do it now in the conference I
mean and not like you can understand
this stuff okay I promise you you can
understand it
but you need to focus okay I'll start
with very simple stuff and we're gonna
get the core thing okay I have a
function that takes a call back okay and
of course I call that call back and I
send the number 10 I mean of course this
will just say 10 10 in the console okay
10 10 of course I could make that
asynchronous I'll just like do a set
interval whoops and I'm gonna send every
1 second
oops I'm gonna send the number I where I
is zero at the beginning and I'm gonna
increment I so it's zero and then it
sends a increment and it sends one and
then increments and since two and so
forth so pretty familiar stuff then it
works like that now I want to add
unsubscribe okay I want to make this
thing stop okay let's say after three
and a half seconds I'm gonna sort of I
want to stop this thing so I'm gonna
register this thing three and a half
seconds I want to sort of clear the
interval but now I'm missing that handle
okay and I need to capture that handle
from the set interval like that okay
and this should probably be a global so
far so good everybody with me okay if
yeah please be with me okay okay so this
this should work last final words right
usually this should work and yeah it
works but this is kind of nasty because
I'm like leaking implementation details
I don't want to say clear interval on a
global because what if I would have a
set in time out here right and there
should be a better way of doing this and
I thought okay what if I put the string
start here and I call numbers with a
string stop okay I
that's pretty easy to do just add type
here and if type is start then we set
the interval if type is stop then we
clear the interval of handle okay so far
so good this is the easy part the hard
part will come soon okay
and it still works I promise you it
still works okay
so hard part comes now I have two pieces
of code I have this piece of code and I
have that piece code
I'm gonna call this part here there's a
there's this thing called region it's
just a comment okay I promise you it's
just a comment
but Visual Studio code knows how to
collapse this comment okay it's just a
comment relax
that's not the hard part actually so and
I'll call this part the sorry region
consumer and and region I'm gonna
collapse that and now I'm gonna draw
some diagram here which really helps for
us and I put the producer on one side
and I'm gonna put the consumer on this
other side so what happens in the
beginning in the beginning we say
numbers start right so we're basically
sending this message to the producer or
sending start right what happens after
that the producer sends me 0 1 2 right
so it sends 0 1 & 2 and after some time
the consumer this region of code sends
stop okay so I'll just right there
stop okay
and now I'm gonna share with you my big
insight it took me four years to
understand this okay it took me four
years okay in other words this is like
subscribe and this is like unsubscribe
right and I'll just call them start and
stop and we know that the consumer is
listening to the producer right we add
on a listener and we're just listening
what are the numbers that you have so of
course the consumer is pretty is
listening to the producer that's easy
usually in rxjs that's the observable
and this is the observer now as these
arrows show you right we get that what
if the consumer would be listening to no
sorry the other way around what if the
producer would be listening to the
consumer when are you gonna tell me
start and when are you gonna
me stop now I don't see your brain
clicking just yet but what I understood
is what if the observer would be
unobservable and observable would be an
observer all right that's what I thought
like whoa this could be something and I
discovered why is there this listener
and there's this thing that can be
listened right why can't they just be
talking to each other and I discovered
that we could make things symmetric with
the symmetry
I'll show you okay you're gonna you're
gonna see so let me just show you what
kind of function we had for the producer
we had this function that took type and
CB it could be also payload and in the
case of start I know that the payload is
a callback and in the case of stop I
don't I don't pass any payload okay you
can think of type and payload kind of
like as Redux
there's type in payload same kind of
idea so with the consumer what's what's
the kind of signal signature for the
function is basically function data and
it returns nothing right that's the
signature for this thing it takes some
data and it just returns you nothing
also the case here so I wanted to unify
these two types of signature this type
and payload void and they it avoids so I
just did like this I just said like what
if here I would also have type and
payload and then this type would be data
and payload would be the data okay why
am i doing this so that these two sides
the producer and the consumer can look
exactly the same but they can still plug
with each other so I'm gonna do that I'm
basically gonna have both of these sides
have the same possible arguments like
that both the producer can get start and
data and stop and also the consumer
get start data and stop okay and I'll
show you how we can convert these things
so let's start from the producer for
instance it's not a region anymore I'll
make a function so it's kind of just
going to call this producer and this is
the payload and once I start this oh
basically once I subscribed once I start
listening to the producer I know that
the payload is a callback right
are you with me are you with me please
be with me because there's no point
being alone here
oh yeah just simplify this code a little
bit okay so I know that CB is the
payload and I know that the CB the
consumer has this type of signature so I
instead of sending the data I'm gonna
send type data and the data okay okay
cool
I'll ignore this part for now and let's
go down to the consumer I'll just make
this a function function consumer type
and payload and what am I gonna do here
is that well if type is data then I'll
just console.log the payload that's the
easy part right this is a listener and
once you say data and it's just gonna
cause a log it but I'm also going to add
start for the consumer so the consumer
will listen to the producer
if type I'm sorry yeah if type equals
start then I know that the payload is
the CB okay and what can I do with that
CB I can say after three and a half
seconds I will send a message to the
producer and I want you to stop I can
see you confused yeah but once I plug
these things together
it's gonna make some sense so the
consumer will send start and the
producer will send start like that
and so far I have just two functions
okay I have functions like that so I
need to do something so that it works
I'll start listening to the producer
oops sorry
but this is essentially it like a
subscribe okay so I'll just say start
its consumer okay let's go step by step
I'm basically passing this callback to
the producer right
and with start this is the this is the
consumer okay and after a while we're
gonna send data to it but I'll also send
the start right because as you see here
I need to send that start so I was
missing that part let's put it here CB
start and producer okay what happens
after that this goes all the way here
and now the consumer knows when to say
stop okay
so the both of them are now listening to
each other because they're having a
conversation and then the consumer is
listening and after that the producer
will say you know what zero and you know
what one and you know what to write and
then after a while the consumer says you
know what I'm done with you
I don't want to hear you anymore she
says stop and we go here and now there's
this unhandled case right we need to
handle the stop but I have this problem
where the handle is not global anymore
that's tricky so I thought how is that
how am I gonna do this because do I put
this global that's not nice I want to do
I'm because the handle is in this block
this block here I have to somehow have
this clear interval somewhere here okay
so what I'm gonna do is okay I'm gonna
add another thing here this callback is
the consumer I promise you so I could
just renamed it like this and you know
start me
means basically subscribe so I can
listen to the consumer with another
function that's a nested callback like
this and then if it's if the type is
stopped then I'll just do clearinterval
handle Oden then that works okay I know
that you're kind of confused so I'll
just go this step-by-step again it
starts here line 27 where does it go to
the producer start it comes here and it
knows what the consumer is it calls it
starts listening to the consumer
after all it sends data to the consumer
the consumer then you know registered
that callback and it also got that data
it got more data and more data and more
data at some point the consumer says
stop and it goes all the way here and
this code works ok I'll show you just
collapse that collapse this one function
a little another function and plugging
them together and no.12 it does what we
wanted to and you might be saying you
know this is kind of like cheating like
it looks like hell now right it looks
like callback hell I mean you got quite
twisted there but the thing is that now
I have hell inside a box ok and you I
have another piece of hell in another
box and I could just plug two pieces of
hell together and get heaven that's kind
of the idea but I'm gonna show something
that rxjs cannot do which is the
consumer sends a piece of data to the
producer because they're having a
conversation in rxjs is basically like
there's a monologue ok you can listen to
that monologue and you can stop
listening to that monologue but it's not
a conversation so here I can send some
data to
the other side let me show you for
instance I could send data and 17 and
then after seven seconds I send stop
okay so then the producer will receive
data and now P is 17 what could I do
with that number well I could do all
kinds of things but I'll just decide
that I'll do I equals P okay yeah and
then it will basically reset this number
here so it's gonna say 17 and then the
following number will be 18 and 19 and
20 so forth
okay and let's run that zero one two and
then it says 17 18 they're having a
conversation two pieces of hell okay so
this is what I called the call bag
pattern okay where the idea is that you
have something nasty you put in the back
and then yeah so it's exactly what I
showed to you and except that I replaced
strings with numbers 0 1 & 2
just to make it like very tight you know
so but the idea is that both of the
consumer and the producer they are
symmetric they have the same signature
and you can write all kinds of operators
for this kind of like rxjs has we have
for instance all of these and this
example is very exciting because you
cannot do this with rxjs and I've seen
plenty of questions where people said
how can I pause and observable okay I
have an observable I want to pause it
you can't definitely you cannot pause an
observable but you can pause a callback
because you can talk to the other side
and say hey stop continue and the kind
of stuff for example here I have a
normal like stream of numbers but then I
say you know stop for a while and then
continue and then stop for a while
and this is very simple type of code
because
you want to see the implementation of
this I mean I'm requiring some libraries
but these are very simple like this is
pipe it's four lines of code what else
this is interval it's essentially what I
showed you what I it's essentially what
I showed you before and you can require
even others like let's say basic map
call back map and I can put it here like
map each number to that number times 104
format for me and then it's just bigger
numbers right and map is very simple as
well it's like super tiny look it's like
what three lines of code four lines of
code right so that's good news actually
because if you want to write real
applications someone wrote to do MVC
David Waller in callbacks and snap Dom
and if you compare this with react Redux
for instance react Redux takes 60
kilobytes and call back to the MVC takes
seven how does the structure inside
those seven look like we have on the
right the application code and on the
left the virtual Dom library in the
middle here we have something like I
don't know ten callback operators how
would this compare with rxjs if you
import rxjs the core library takes at
least five kilobytes and on top of that
operators the core of callbacks is zero
kilobytes because it's it's not a
library it's not a library it's a
pattern of writing callbacks and all of
these 1.5 kilobytes include ten
operators because they're just four
lines of code five lines of code that
kind of stuff also it's slightly faster
than rxjs
in the benchmarks that I made but the
thing that excites me most is how the
community took this because you know if
it's just five lines of code even though
it's very tricky and it's like Hell in a
box you could write it I mean seriously
just sit down and think about it you
could write
and that's what people did so I built
some basic operators like 20 of them and
that was in February but by now we have
around a hundred and ten and most of
these were built by the community so I
didn't build most of these and you can
find them in the wiki if you write one
you can add it to the wiki there's ways
of converting from the keyboard or from
the gamepad or interval or reddit or
converting from observables converting
from promises converting from nodejs
streams converting from iterables
converting from all kinds of stuff and
you can convert it back to a sink weight
you can convert it to intervals or rxjs
you could transform it in multiple
different ways
variations of map and you can filter
them in all kinds of ways and a lot of
the behavior of rxjs is here already and
this is this is what really excited me
because some of the people who made
libraries for callbacks they were that
was their first library because it's so
small and it's so simple I mean it is
tricky and an intricate but it's it it's
intricate in a box and I'm sure that
probably some of you didn't understand
what I said but let's meet at the
discussion corner I can go through all
the details of what I said and I believe
that this is the way forward using the
language that we have is actually very
powerful can do everything that we need
and that's it I hope I convinced you
that the path to the callback heaven is
narrow and and few go through it okay
thank you
[Applause]